Next, let's talk about how we might approach the design of our project today.
So we can start off by looking at UMG, which is Unreal Engine's motion graphic system.
It's a 2D slash 3D user interface designer.
You can mock up UI directly inside of Unreal Engine.
All of this content, maybe except this icon here was created inside of Unreal Engine.
So you can draw text.
You can have slider bars.
You can have little pop out buttons.
It's very modular in nature.
And it's very useful to begin prototyping any kind of content you might need for your projects.
When we talk about touch screens, we want to make sure the icons are nice and large in our projects.
We want to assume that the user is distracted.
The roads are bumpy.
Consider spacing out UI elements.
So making sure we're considering the borders and the grids and just making sure the overall interface is nice and straightforward to use.
We, of course, want to make sure accessibility is kept in mind at all times.
So any kind of high contrast modes, colorblind modes, any kind of outline on text that will support the user is really useful to consider at this stage.
When we display data management, we can think about widgets as templates.
When you're thinking about child widgets, we can create elements with default value from a custom class.
So essentially, if you're going to be reusing a lot of information and you don't want to keep making the same UI element again and again,
we can have a parent widget that holds all the main information.
And then what we can do is we can create a child widget from that parent widget and it can consume the data from the parent.
But then you can also override specific variables or options that you want to kind of customize to this child class.
And it's just a much cleaner way to work.
It means that if you want to change any of the larger structure, you can do so in the parent class.
And then the child class, even if the child class was made after the fact, it will still inherit those new properties.
So if you have to make a change, you only make the change once in the parent class and then it deploys across all the child classes as well.
So it can also prevent larger bugs and issues and things like this.
We have slate brushes, which are reusable brush strokes as well that we can be used in inside of Unreal Engine.
And also, as we mentioned on the previous slide, the text displays any kind of text you want.
Say you want the vehicle speed displaying and we want to update the speed at runtime.
We can bind specific elements of text and we can also format that text all at runtime.
So if values are changing, we can do this inside of UNG.
We also have rich text, which the rich text block uses a data table asset to manage the styles and the customization of your projects.
We can also embed video into our UI projects here.
So we use the media framework in this instance.
So you can just right click anywhere in your content browser, go to the media option.
And on the media section, you can go to the file media source here.
We've got the media textures, media player and the playlist.
If you want to get more information about how to use video inside your projects, there's a really good Unreal Engine documentation page,
which if you just type in Unreal Engine docs media framework, it'll come up for you and a very straightforward process.
But it's more of a step by step how to on how to get videos inside your project.
So the really useful thing about the video is it can be rendered either in 2D or 3D.
So you can see in the screenshot, we've actually placed a plane in the world, which we can use to project the video.
So it can either be overlaid on the screen in 2D or it can be projected in the world as 3D.
And all videos are in your content folder and in movies.
So when you have your projects and you have a content folder with the various blueprints and assets that you've created,
we just want to create a movies folder there to store all of our raw movies, which Unreal Engine then streams from that movie content folder.
And when we're looking at performance interfaces, material complexity can be a useful thing to highlight here.
It can increase the pixel cost of a render.
So the more instructions there are for each pixel, the more time the render needs to spend calculating its final value.
So opaque materials on a UI, the least expensive, but can differ greatly based on the shading model or the base shader code.
So if you're wanting any slightly transparent buttons, just know that it can come with a cost.
So we can find more information.
Again, documentation is a really good resource to start digging into.
So you can look at the testing and optimization documentation to find more information about this.
And then there's also a documentation page on interactive experiences, which is a really good user best practice guide.
So we can talk about performance in relation to project specific outcome.
You just want to be thinking about that early on, making sure you get all your UI elements on the screen.
If you're wanting to store any data from this UI, you can use the game instance, which means there's less loading and unloading.
As we were talking about before, if there's any kind of permanent storing and data, you want to use the game instance there.
And we also have UMG tools built into the editor, which we have widget switches and user created widget components,
which allows you to interact with any other custom components or between multiple widgets at the same time.
Say you want to toggle through multiple screens or anything like this.
We have that functionality inside the engine.